Guten morgen guten morgen tim.
Ein bisschen zu spät ich habe nur noch toilettenpapier mit mandelmilch aroma bekommen.
Aux
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundert vom vierzehnten.
Mittendrin in eine krise hier.
Mittendrin werden wir noch sehen aber.
Ja und ja wir dann mal wieder von angesicht zu angesicht nachdem wir ein paar sendungen remote gestalten mussten.
Aber social disziplin haben wir hier trotzdem.
Hier wird nicht gespuckt kein beatboxing.
Kein beatbox kein beatbox ne und der distanz die distanz hier ist glaube ich ausreichend.
Sicherheitsabstand ist ja gewährt gewart.
Deutschland hat ja jetzt mehr epidemiologische als bundestrainer.
Neuerdings ja.
Aber ihr wisst es gibt nur einen rudi völler und unser unser rudi völler ist christian trosten.
Und und auch dicht gefolgt team chefin oder eine teamchef ist ja dann wie heißt der robert koch vom hof.
Hoher koch-institut wie heißt er denn der.
Das robin koch der chef vom robert-koch-institut das weiß ich leider nicht auswendig.
Wie der wie der zweite mann der auf dem mond gelandet ist.
Du bist ja ein zwei gewesen.
Und weil aber dicht gefolgt hier mit.
Lothar wieder ist der präsident wenn du den mainz.
Und und marilyn eddo oder addon dass eine professorin in ich glaube hamburg,
die habe ich auch gesehen die war auch irre ja auch sehr sehr gut erklärt sehr besonnen die sich mit den mit der impfung impfstoff entwicklung und so auseinandersetzt,
also.
Wir stellen also fest man hört wieder auf wissenschaftler das ja mal was neues.
In deutschland in den usa.
Noch nicht so auch noch nicht so.
Wobei donald trump hat das ja alles verstanden der der hat ja dann also die haut die hauptbotschaft als er sich mit dem center für die kontrolle getroffen hat war ja die beeindruckt die ärzte waren dass er das alles versteht weil er so klug ist.
Ich habe doch gar keine lust über diesen vogel zu reden und ich will jetzt nicht meine innersten wünsche zu sehr nach außen kehren aber soll er ruhig mal weiterhin zu schütteln.
Es war nicht alles schlecht mit corona wer weiß ähm.
Vielleicht.
Es gibt ich würde gerne was sind noch also ordentliche quellen weil.
Jetzt kursieren ja auch schon irgendwelche whatsapp-nachrichten,
wo irgendwelche leute meinen irgendwelche informationen herausgeben zu wollen und so.
Ein ein scheiß nach dem anderen also bitte bitte bitte informiert euch.
Bei denen die ahnung haben dieser podcast der wochen täglich kommt korona virus update mit christian drosseln ist eine absolute empfehlung absoluter.
Also super ganz toll jeden tag eine halbe stunde erscheint mittags haben wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch eh abonniert das ist aber das absolute pflichtprogramm zur stunde informationen wie ihr euch zu verhalten habt und so kriegt ihr beim,
robert-koch-institut und in den ordentlichen medien,
bitte bitte bitte jetzt nicht in irgendwelche whatsapp kettenbrief e verfallen wo euch irgendein schluss gemeldet wird informationen gibt es von den leuten die ahnung haben und die leute die auf whatsapp sind,
und euch irgendwelche kettenbrief e schreiben gehören nicht dazu.
Das gilt natürlich nicht nur für whatsapp sein dich für eigentlich alle digitalen medien.
Stimmt zum beispiel wenn wie heißt der der cox aus aus ibiza chris hans-christian strache der hat jetzt auch gesagt man soll jede viertelstunde was trinken ja weil dann spürt man das virus runter und in der magensäure stirbt das.
Da soll er machen aber bitte nur er.
Rate ihm dazu das zu tun ja vielleicht auch alle fünf minuten was trinken der scheint ja ey gerne zu trinken aber bitte bitte bitte,
konzentriert euch auf die ernstzunehmenden informationen und expertinnen in dem bereich und macht auch was die sagen.
Ja ich bin gespannt also ich meine wenn schon impfgegner ihre demos absagen dann.
Wohne dazu gezwungen.
Frau von.
Wenn der corona history.
Also die hysterie selber war jetzt sozusagen die verschwörung.
Sie wollten eine schöne corona party feiern.
Ja also ja bitte lass uns nicht zu sehr abdriften wir würden da jetzt auch so eine menge witze einfallen aber die die kriegen wir noch dann gleich wieder um die ohren geschlagen ist überhaupt eine sehr schwierige situation,
der jede debatte irgendwie sehr kritisch beleuchtet wird zurecht aber ich finde ja auch,
es muss möglich sein jetzt hier auch mal ein bisschen über den tellerrand,
hinauszudenken weil das ganze thema wird uns natürlich auch noch sehr lange beschäftigen und extrem viele auswirkungen haben ein paar davon wo man hier auch gleich nochmal,
ansprechen es gibt natürlich wirtschaftliche auswirkungen es gibt vor allem viele auswirkungen glaube ich die wir noch gar nicht so richtig auf der kette haben,
also auswirkungen von auswirkungen von auswirkungen das ist einfach so ein diverses feld und natürlich blickt man immer erstmal nur auf,
auf das was aktuell gerade so brennt und und und debattiert wird und wo man glaubt richtige informationen zu erhalten,
aber auch wichtig,
die ganze entwicklung im blick zu behalten und sich schon auch mal auf auswirkungen einzurichten die eben vielleicht,
nächste woche nächsten monat oder vielleicht auch erst bitte dieses jahres akut werden.
Ja
ich möchte tatsächlich uns jetzt hier in diesem bereich kurz halten und auf das konzentrieren von dem wir eine ahnung haben und das beurteilen der epidemiologische situation den epidemiologische überlassen.
Na klar also ich wollte nicht über demo logie reden sondern sozusagen welche gesellschaftlichen
auswirkungen das hat und die sind ja vielfältig so manches wird sich vielleicht ja auch mit unseren kernthemen paaren auch wenn die liste jetzt noch nicht so lange und aufdringlich ist aber.
Also zunächst einmal ist zu sagen,
die sozialen medien haben was sehr schönes getan für uns und zwar gibt es ein video das wir gerade gesehen haben von einem gabelstapler führer
in einem holland offenbar in einem großen lager der durch eine ich wusste nicht dass die menschheit so viel klopapier hat ja fährt
einfach die ganze zeit nur laut lacht und sagt hier für die die ganze klopapier gekauft haben ich glaube nicht dass das so schnell alle geht und er fährt also wirklich durch,
also es gibt genug toilettenpapier es gibt genug toilettenpapier und,
selbst wenn es keines mehr gäbe wäre das euer geringstes problem weil sich neben eurer toilette eine dusche befindet mit der ihr euch reinigen könntet also hört auf dieses dämliche klopapier aufzukaufen,
und ich habe mir auch überlegt was jetzt also weil ja bei so viel klopapier wie gekauft wurde gehe ich davon aus dass ich auch unter unseren hörerinnen und hörern leute befinden die jetzt irgendwie von allen dingen klopapier gestockt peilt haben ihr macht jetzt folgendes.
Hier geht mal zu den nachbarn und klingelt und sagt hallo ich wollte nur sagen ich bin der arsch der ganze klopapier gekauft hat.
Tut mir leid braucht ihr welches so und wenn die nachbarn dann sagen nee ich habe selber ganz.
Dann sagt er komm dann gucken wir jetzt wenn wir das weg gekauft haben so irgendeiner sitzt nämlich das in dem fall wirklich ich mit mandelmilch wir jetzt da.
So das ist das ist wirklich es ist unsinn das zu tun die versorgung wird nicht zusammenbrechen so schnell und vor allem gerade toilettenpapier meine güte ja.
Man muss dazu sagen,
die angst glaube ich ist vielfältig aber was natürlich manche befürchten ist dass ich in gewisser hinsicht die anordnung weiter verschärfen das ist ja zumindest nicht auszuschließen
oder dass man eben selber auf einmal betroffen ist und eben in irgendeine form von quarantäne sich selbst,
und dann möglichst wenig rausgehen will und offensichtlich scheint klopapier das zu sein.
Ich habe immer klopapier braucht wie immer nicht rausgehen.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen
ich kann das nachvollziehen aber es gibt einfach klopapier dann einfach nur in zu großen packungen ja es hätte ja so ein zweier rollen dings gibt's ja teilweise auch aber davon gibt es dann einfach nicht genug du hast ja nur die großen pakete und die kannst du ja da nicht einzeln kaufen.
Kleine pakete toiletten.
Ja aber dann nicht so viele.
Guck dir doch mal im supermarkt zum klopapier regal an da ist wirklich das allermeiste sind so sechser achter zehner zwölfer paket kann ja nicht groß genug sein da gibt's dann halt nicht so viele einzelne produkte die du überhaupt kaufen kannst.
Diskussion war alle gewartet.
Dir anguckst wie die wie die karren vollgepackt sind mit toilettenpapier dann wirst du schon sehen wie viele toilettenpapier du dir kaufen kannst ja.
Und fast jeder mensch der.
In diese lage käme zuhause isoliert sein zu müssen wird eine andere person fragen können ob sie ihm einen einkauf tätigt und den vor die tür stellt.
Oder einfach zwei rollen klopapier abgibt.
Ja und weißt du aber wer das wär das nicht wem diese solidarität unter umständen nicht zugute kommen könnte,
das sind die leute mit dem ganzen arsch papier die da sitzen ihr wurdet nämlich gesehen ja ihr wolltet gesehen.
Das habt ihr von der videoüberwachung.
Ich weiß ganz genau wer von meinem nachbarn was mitgebracht kriegt und wenn.
Oh man.
Das ist wirklich das sind.
Einfach unnötige erschwerung erschwernissen auch für die menschen die das dann brauchen es ist jetzt wirklich also ne,
diese das also lasst es lasst es sein ist quatsch und teilt es jetzt solidarisch,
sonst steht ihr nämlich da wie dieser typ der aus den aus den usa der siebzehntausend siebenhundert flaschen hand desinfektionsmittel gekauft hat irgendwie im januar,
angefangen hat das auf amazon teuer zu verkaufen,
und amazon hat ihn jetzt wegen wucher den account gesperrt und jetzt hat er eine garage voll mit sechzehntausendsiebenhundert handdesinfektionsmittel flaschen.
Kriegt ihr nicht verkauft und woanders fehlen die also da muss halt jetzt einfach mal dann der staat einreiten dem eine fresse hauen und,
eigentlich finde ich es gut wenn sie das lager anzünden würden aber am besten dem sie's dann mit und bringst dahin wo es gebraucht wird
ok aber also hamster käufe werden so schnell nicht notwendig sein selbst in italien wo es einen look down gab war die versorgungslage sichergestellt das ist auch nicht besonders schwierig das aufrecht zu erhalten,
weil leute halt die lieferfahrzeuge ist ja alles einfach besetzt so das funktioniert müsst ihr euch keine sorgen machen,
schulen werden zugemacht tim.
Tja das weiß ich schon.
Ja
Wurde ich von informiert das wird eine interessante belastung werden also im allgemeinen ich mache mir jetzt persönlich,
nicht so viel sorgen aber es gibt natürlich leute die jobs haben wo das eben nicht so einfach ist das hängt ja dann im wesentlichen auch vor dem alter der kinder ab umso jünger die sind umso schwieriger kita und grundschule,
gymnasialen oberstufe also oberstufe ältere kinder können dann im wesentlichen auch schon selber klarkommen aber bei kleinkids da musst du halt irgendeiner form präsent sein,
und nicht jeder job des homeoffice fähig.
Das ist richtig aber die die homeoffice fähig sind sollten das natürlich jetzt machen.
Wenn's das internet hergibt.
Ja da kommen wir nämlich jetzt auch langsam in dem bereich der für uns natürlich eine rolle spielt da gibt es das internet her ich hatte mit thomas ein bisschen gesprochen thomas lobinger der ja hier auch regelmäßig in der sendung ist,
sagte so ja was ist denn jetzt keine mobilfunk letzte mal langsam das volumen fallen lassen begrenzung.
Das wäre in der tat eine gute idee.
Gleichzeitig ist aber auch tatsächlich so dass die deutsche telekom fährt jetzt schon in einem notfall modus ne also die oder so ein die haben jetzt quasi ressourcen aufgestockt und so ja also der djk keks hatte seine rekord durchsatz,
mal gucken wie das ist wie lange netflixen dann tatsächlich noch vermittelt wird oder ob dann,
notgedrungen irgendwelche netzneutralität einschränkungen stattfinden müssen um die ganzen zuhause sitzenden netflix cooker home of homeoffice sorry.
Zu grenzen da da werden wir auf jeden fall auf probleme schauen aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich das wichtigste jetzt ist.
Toilettenpapier und so weiter alles auf seite was jetzt wichtig ist leute ist dass ihr euch bitte bitte ordentliche headsets kauft,
und dass ihr dann googelt wie die taste funktioniert oder noch besser ein audio klein mit push-to-talk-button benutzt,
wo ihr eine taste drückt wenn ihr etwas sagt und wenn ihr während der telefonkonferenz kacken geht oder mit dem kind spielt oder.
Klingt so als hättest du der erfahrungen gemacht in diesem bereich.
Ich bin homeoffice geschädigt da ja ich kann euch da alle tricks sagen,
nein holt euch bitte ein vernünftiges headset es ist anders nicht zu ertragen wenn dann da irgendwelche leute auf ihren computern rum trommeln tippen und und das sind diese blech mikrofone die da drin sind
da könnt ihr jetzt hamster kaufen wenn ihr homeoffice macht kauft euch ein schönes headset ich mache auch amazon affiliate links in die shownotes könnt ihr schöne headsets kaufen,
das tatsächliche problem was ich aber glaube dass das einzige ist was eigentlich unterbelichtet gerade ist oder in der wahrnehmung die ich sehe.
Die ich bisher habe ist das risiko der depression,
das ohnehin ein risiko in unserer gesellschaft ist dass sehr viele menschen erreicht und in einer solchen phase,
durchaus eine schwer eine eine rolle spielt wir befinden uns jetzt in einer,
phase von angst und ungewissheit ja viele menschen werden massive ökonomische einbußen hinnehmen müssen das geht los mit,
leuten die vielleicht im servicebereich tätig sind in der gastronomie.
Das kann weitergehen mit leuten die diese gastronomie betreiben das geht über selbstständige wie mich weiter da werden also durchaus sehr viele,
ja ökonomische sorgen auf menschen zu kommen.
Dann diese isolation zu hause das social distance zing reiz armut generell ne also ich war jetzt längere zeit nicht in meiner wohnung im moment finde ich echt noch ganz gut.
Das wird sich zeitnah ändern und die verringerung der sozialen aktivität,
ist natürlich auch ein problem und dann wenn,
vor allem wenn menschen dann wirklich in einem lok down sind oder,
in der verordneten quarantäne fallen ausgleich aktivitäten weg also sport radfahren was auch immer und da müsst ihr euch,
spätestens dann wirklich ernsthaft gedanken drüber machen dagegen anzuarbeiten dass da eine depression einsetzt,
weil wenn die dann da ist dann wird das schwierig und,
da jetzt mal eine kleine empfehlung.
So das ist jetzt nicht abgeschlossen aber das sind so die sachen die auf jeden fall immer empfohlen werden.
Gleichzeitig weiß ich auch depression ist so ein thema.
Wenn ich da jetzt darüber spreche dann werden die werden sich jetzt sehr viele menschen angesprochen fühlen und sagen dass das thema jetzt aber falsch behandelt habe oder dass ich mich jetzt irgendwie klug fühle nur weil ich diplom psychologe bin,
jede depression ist anders und ich möchte hier jetzt einfach für menschen die damit auch noch keine erfahrung haben einfach mal ein paar präventive,
maßnahmen empfehlen also grundsätzlich,
aktivitäts aufbau ist das höchste ziel der depressionen prävention und der depressionen behandlung,
also ihr müsst euch wirklich dann aufgabe suchen ja die,
erledigt bar sind und in irgendeiner form auch andere so abschließbar was weiß ich ne das geht los mit aufräumen und putzen,
dateien auf euren computern sortieren backups machen sachen wegräumen fotos sortieren ja es gibt eine ganze reihe aufgaben die,
ihr erledigen könnt wenn ihr da jetzt in so 'ner wohnung sitzt und isoliert seid,
ich würde nicht unbedingt dazu raten so den ganzen tag irgendwo im liegen zu verbringen,
oder netflix zu gucken das würde ich vermeiden dass wäre er der weg in eben aktivitäts abbau und so und das da kommt ihr eine depression näher wenn ihr in dieser situation seid.
Bewegung ja,
irgendeine form von kalorienverbrauch oder sport es gibt eine ganze reihe an apps die so trainingsprogramme machen die funktionieren ohne dass ihr dafür irgendwelche geräte braucht,
also ich weiß nicht genau wie viele seven minute apps es gibt ne wo dann irgendwie und hier.
Die beugen langes.
Einfach nur laufen wenn man es kann also das hilft schon sehr.
Auf der stelle laufen also ich gehe jetzt so solange ihr raus können macht natürlich spaziergänge macht das ich habe mich da heute auch ausführlich zu gezwungen eine längere fahrradtour zu machen wer weiß wie lange das noch geht,
und da also wirklich richtet euch da jetzt drauf ein weil das die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr eine längere zeit zuhause verbringen müsst ist da,
fangt damit jetzt an es geht nicht darum es geht hin bei diesen empfehlungen nicht darum dass ihr zuhause sitzt und sagt oh scheiße jetzt habe ich eine depression jetzt manchmal sieben minuten sport dann geht die weg das wird nicht passieren ihr müsst es genau andersrum haben bis jetzt dagegen arbeiten,
genuss und entspannung ja sagt sich so leicht daher wird auch jede person die depression mal erlebt hat sagen ja ja genau.
Stimmt hast umso wichtiger auch hier jetzt damit anzufangen es gibt eine reihe an,
keine ahnung irgendwelche apps oder hörbücher die man wo man sich mit meditations methoden auseinandersetzen kann und genuss.
Kann man eben auch,
schulen ja also sei es sich einen einen ordentlichen tee zu holen und sich damit auseinandersetzt zu setzen den halt zuzubereiten,
jetzt gerade auch zum beispiel feine teesorten zuhause die ich dann mit einer kanne und höchster sorgfalt da irgendwie,
den ganzen quatsch die da drauf schreiben irgendwie eine dreißig sekunden bei dieser wassertemperatur und dann drei flaschen und hast alle nicht gesehen mache ich jetzt.
Backbrot.
Vor allem man hat jetzt immer das ist eine riesen gelegenheit man hat jetzt mal so die zeit dinge zu tun die sonst vielleicht,
schwierig waren auch weil sie so eine längere betreuungszeit braucht also brot backen will ich gerade deshalb,
wenn du so richtig machen willst da hast du so sauerteig ansetzen oder irgendwie so ein kleines hefewasser gemischt und dann muss das erstmal ein paar stunden stehen und dann zwölf stunden später soll es in den nächsten schritt machen und dann nochmal den teig oder muss er nochmal drei stunden gehen und so wenn man diese zeit einfach so hat
da kann man sich wunderbar da reinmachen kann noch was lernen dabei bücher lesen podcast hören.
Podcast hören ja brotbacken ist eine super idee ich habe auch noch brotbackmischung zuhause.
Die habe ich auch gedacht.
Na also genuss schweine und wirklich diese sachen dann das muss dann eben zelebriert werden da muss man sich dann die zeit zu nehmen und dann müsst ihr irgendwie euer selbstgebackenes brot
ich höre dass sowieso überall das meer gerade aufgekauft ist insofern scheint einige von euch da schon vor zu haben ja da,
hört ihr das das ist gut ja und alles was ich jetzt sage fangt damit jetzt an nicht in zwei wochen oder sonst was.
Vor allem mit dem backups.
Backups das hauptproblem was wir natürlich in diese situation haben ist es fehlt der soziale austausch,
das ist nicht zu unterschätzen menschen sehen mit menschen sprechen menschen in arm nehmen und sonst was also,
gerne anfangen,
telefonieren skypen die beziehung die ihr so habt stabil halten leute mal anrufen fragen wie es ihnen geht.
Wir haben gestern schon mal geübt wir haben eine virtuelle kneipe aufgemacht.
Lieber einen online videokonferenz dienst unserer wahl,
und dann saßen da alle am computer und haben sich unterhalten war ein nettes ründchen hatten auch alle einwandfrei headsets ja das ist nämlich der punkt haben wir auch darüber gesprochen,
du willst in einer solchen situation kompetenz.
Und gelassenheit und vor allem dominanz zeigen indem du ein vernünftiges headset hast.
Das scheint sich wirklich zu beschäftigen das thema.
Natürlich das ist das headset ist das headset was was im anhalter das handtuch ist ja ist in korea in der corolla krise ein headset.
Der typ war es wirklich wo sein headset ist.
Ein ordentliches headset.
Nein aber genau telefonieren skypen stabil halten den leuten sagen ey ich wollte mal fragen wie es dir geht und so weiter ein bisschen bisschen quatschen und all das,
bitte einbauen in einen geregelten tagesablauf lasst euch das von einem erfahrenen home-office sagen,
das hat was morgens zu einer bestimmten uhrzeit den wecker gestellt zu haben zu dieser uhrzeit,
oder vielleicht eine halbe stunde später aufzustehen zu duschen tee zu kochen kochen oder was auch immer und sich eine hose anzuziehen,
das ist,
das gehört sich so ja und das hilft das hilft dem tag struktur zu geben feste zeiten für die mahlzeiten ungefähr einhalten dass man sagt okay um diese uhrzeit frühstücke ich um diese uhrzeit esse ich mittag um diese uhrzeit esse ich abends.
Auch gerade morgens ganz tolle idee.
Morgens.
Dann erstmal duschen dann fühlt man sich schon mal wunderbar bisschen ausgepowert schon mal richtig sauber gemacht.
Sehr gute idee.
Und dann kaffee und wenn ihr noch hafermilch bekommen habt.
Und dann geht ihr an euren wenn ihr jetzt in ins home-office entlassen wurde dann geht ihr,
an einem arbeitsplatz bestenfalls den ihr euch zu diesem zweck eingerichtet habt vielleicht habt ihr ja auch schon einen arbeitsplatz zu hause wenn nicht,
gebe ich hier mal ein paar tipps welches dieser arbeitsplatz nicht ist zum beispiel euer bett,
oder euer sofa das ist nicht der arbeitsplatz dass ihr euer bett oder euer sofa der arbeitsplatz ist am besten ein zu diesem zwecke gestalteter tisch auf dem steht dann euer laptop an dem laptop das headset.
Strom papiere die ihr da bearbeiten müsst oder was auch immer und dann schafft ihr euch einen arbeitsplätze dieser arbeitsplatz wird betreten und verlassen ich habe seit mehreren jahren arbeite ich wenn ich zu hause bin im home-office,
und ich bin immer wieder dieser satz ist nicht hundertprozentig richtig weil ich zu diesem sagen muss dass ich immer wieder zwischendurch mir ein büro arbeitsplatz,
gewünscht habe oder auch organisiert habe weil einem irgendwann die decke auf den kopf fällt zu hause und das ist da bitte neue also home homeoffice novizen bitte,
darauf achten dass ihr euch einen arbeitsplatz einrichtet den ihr betretet und verlasst und als solchen dann eben auch wahrnimmt hat der tim ja hier auch der hat ja sein studio,
und seinen ganzen den palast der der podcast palast der ist eben woanders.
Perfekter garten da hinterher.
Das sind ganz karges studio,
sorgt dafür dass er nennt der nicht während der arbeit noch eure verschwitzten unterwäsche irgendwie auf dem boden liegt also sorgt dafür für struktur.
Und ich denke das sind jetzt so diese empfehlung also bewegung auf bewegungs aufbau,
generell aktivitäts aufbauen nicht rumhängen sondern tätigkeiten suchen tätigkeiten die abschließbar sind also also wo man wo man auch ein erfolgserlebnis hat das jetzt getan zu haben.
Genuss und entspannung beachten ja genuss und entspannung sollte jetzt nicht,
einfach vereinheitlicht werden und alkohol sein ja das wäre auch tatsächlich etwas wovon ich mich jetzt hin zunehmenden maße fernhalten würde wären irgendwelche rauschmittel also alkohol oder was ihr sonst so alles,
durch egal welche körperöffnung konsumiert das ist nicht unbedingt die zeit dafür aufgrund der,
nachwirkungen die diese mittel haben kommt er da schneller in,
auf schräge touren sozialen austausch aufrecht erhalten gerne eben auch visualisiert.
Und einen geregelten tagesablauf und das sind so die grundmaxime nahmen die jetzt für leute die mehr zeit in ihrer wohnung verbringen müssen,
denke ich geboten sind und das gilt genauso für homeoffice leute als auch irgendwie freiwillig selbst garantin technisiert und die menge an menschen die.
Unter umständen eben auch in isolation müssen.
Sicherlich gibt es auch noch mehr empfehlungen freue ich mich wenn die in den,
in den shownotes hätte ich jetzt schon gesagt in den kommentaren beigetragen werden und wünsche euch eine schöne krise.
Ja gute hinweise auf jeden fall die ganze digital debatte,
kommt so ein bisschen am rande hoch.
So also sozusagen was liegt das jetzt irgendwas offen also man man sieht jetzt erstmal den wert von internet zuhause.
Also die frage mit wozu brauche ich denn das überhaupt zu hause so hat sich ja über die jahre auch so ein bisschen gewandelt von brauche ich überhaupt und bräuchte unbedingt dsl und warum muss ich denn immer verbunden sein und,
wozu brauche ich denn eine schnelle leitung und wozu bräuchte einen schnellen blink ich lad doch nur runter.
Ja das sind alles so sachen die sich jetzt sozusagen in dieser phase komplett neu sortieren,
das ist sowas zu dieser arbeitsplatz betrifft wenn man eben schon im normalen berufsleben steht aber es hat ja jetzt zum beispiel auch enorme auswirkungen auf schule und universitäten die jetzt auch alle dicht machen,
und nicht so richtig wissen wie sie denn irgendwie weitermachen sollen und,
so richtig voran gekommen sind wir da in deutschland nicht das kann man nicht sagen all die ganzen initiativen die da gestartet waren waren alles.
Rohrkrepierer kann man im prinzip sagen da hat sich nicht wirklich was gewandelt ja es macht keinen sinn wenn man irgendwie schulen mit,
irgendwie pcs flutet für die dann keine
admins da sind vor allem in dieser situation hilft dir das halt auch nicht weiter weil du hast irgendwie keine die schüler haben nicht irgendwie ein gerät was sie dann irgendwie auch woanders benutzen können die verbindung es gibt keine server infrastruktur es gibt vor allem.
Ja wir haben doch wir haben noch eine schöne digitale tafel.
Genau sowas hast du dann halt so eine digitale tafel sonst kriech ding was er irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch nach zwei jahren wieder wegschmeißen kannst falls du keine ab jetzt für gibt.
All das haben wir nicht und vor allem haben wir auch diese strukturen nicht ich hab vorhin noch auf twitter ein tweet gesehen von,
jürgen handgelds vor fünf jahren schon mal einen podcast gemacht habe.
Jürgen handke ist so ein hoff in in marburg,
unterrichtet englisch ja und er hat schon früh eingesehen,
dass du dieses immer wieder repetitiv oh gott ich erzähle hier in jedem semester den leuten immer wieder dasselbe vollkommen nutzlos ist und hat dann irgendwie angefangen,
komplette methode vollständig jetzt basiert umzudrehen also dieses konzeptes umgedrehten klassenzimmers flip classroom,
durchzusetzen und,
gibt es einen schönen verlinken wir nochmal den podcast auf forschergeist kann man sich echt mal anhören und da steckt so viel da steckt so viel.
Klares drin so was sozusagen nicht nur jetzt in dieser situation sehr hilfreich wäre,
sondern eben auch für den normalen ablauf total sinnvoll ist weil es einfach auch die lehrenden komplett befreit von von von überflüssigen doppel maßnahmen also warum sollst du grundwissen jedes semester immer wieder dieselbe vorlesung halten,
mehr oder weniger die dieselben informationen kurz gesagt jetzt einfach umgedreht hat einfach gesagt so,
hier hallo ihr neuen studenten super hier sind irgendwie die videos zieht ihr euch mal rein da ist das grundwissen das müsst ihr drauf haben.
So wenn ihr das macht und wie oft er das macht und ob ihr euch das fünfmal anhört oder einmal und dann habt ihr es schon kaputt ist mir doch egal ihr müsst es nur drauf haben und,
an die uni kommt ihr dann erst wenn ihr in so einem kleinen kurzen online-test bewiesen hat dass er irgendwie diese,
informationen aufgenommen habt und dann dann kriegt ihr quasi die eigentliche präsenz und die ist dann halt hoch interaktiv speziell auf eure bedürfnisse zugeschnitten et cetera pp wer sich die ganzen podcast nach erzählen aber das.
Und da ist halt ist halt wenig geschehen und vielleicht ist das jetzt eben auch so ein moment wo man dann mal wieder neu darüber nachdenken wie man sowas organisieren kann auch über die krise hinaus.
Zunächst stellt sich natürlich die frage und da denke ich können auch unter unseren zuhörerinnen und zuhörer sich wahrscheinlich noch einige leute befinden,
wir werden jetzt eben sehen dass das mit dieser mit dieser,
bildung so nicht so gut funktioniert und ich glaube dass es hier eine reihe an technologien gibt die.
Insbesondere für so einen notfall betrieb der jetzt hier bei einigen schulen,
mal aufrecht erhalten werden könnte sollte müsste dass man da durchaus was hätte um um.
Den unterricht auch digital weiterzuführen da stellen sich aber dann nämlich fragen wie.
Haben alle kinder ein geeignetes endgerät oder müssen vielleicht die die fünf von den geeigneten endgeräten haben mal eins abtreten.
Oder können sind die leer der lehrer in der lage hat der lehrer ein vernünftiges headset damit geht's ja los.
Oder die lehrerin die hat aber wahrscheinlich eins so und,
solche da glaube ich bietet sich jetzt hier für unsere nadine und nerds durchaus die möglichkeit vielleicht auch in ihrem in ihrem schulbereich oder dem ihrer kinder,
wirkung zu entfalten gestern schon irgendwie so ein tweet gelesen wurde eine tochter also eine schülerin,
irgendwie ein discord server aufgesetzt hat für die für die klasse ja und jetzt muss er nur noch den dem lehrer erklären das ist jetzt das sind jetzt die die zeiten um die wo wir mal wieder,
oder wo wir dann auch mal einen beitrag leisten können der eine rolle spielen kann weil.
Das eben leider nicht vorgesorgt wurde.
Ja mit der vorsorge ist dann auch so eine sache die sich das wirtschaftliche alles auswirken wird also in gewisser hinsicht,
haben wir natürlich in deutschland schon die ein oder andere maßnahme also ich weiß nicht ganz genau welcher zustand offiziell erreicht werden soll um so kurzarbeit zu ermöglichen also das dann staatliche hilfen.
Auch gezahlt werden leute arbeiten weniger kriegen aber trotzdem geld,
dass wir jetzt auf jeden fall angekommen aber das trifft natürlich mal wieder nur die leute die eben in so einer festen angestellten beziehung sind oder arbeiter beziehungen sind,
schwierig ist es für selbständige ist es.
Mein selbstständige haben es ohnehin nicht leicht also das ist viele unserer,
fangnetze die wir so in unserem sozialsystem haben,
da stellt sich dann bei selbstständigen immer wieder ganz anders da fängt schon bei krankenversicherung an wo als selbstständige in der regel extrem hohe beiträge zu zahlen haben weil es halt einfach niemanden gibt der den anderen teil,
bezahlt
und natürlich sind jetzt auch selbstständige die ersten die in so einer situation abgehängt werden na klar muss ich nachher erstmal um die die angestellt sind und mit denen du eine feste vertragsbeziehungen hast,
die muss ich natürlich erstmal kümmern aber alle leute die von auftrag zu auftrag leben sind natürlich in so einer krisensituation die ersten die darunter leiden und das halt unter umständen schon vom ersten tag an also,
muss ich ja nur anschauen was jetzt im veranstaltungsbereich abgeht.
Messebauer drinnen und bauer.
Genau konzerte alles mögliche die ganzen heinz,
das das geht sehr weiter könnte man jetzt sehr viel aufzählen und ja in der regel haben dann eben selbstständige auch nicht unbedingt jetzt immer so die back-ups am start mit denen sie mal eben so ein paar monate überleben können.
Dich betrifft das ja auch.
Mich betrifft auch ja ich habe durchaus einige einbußen gerade,
bist du jetzt noch nicht genau wann mein nächster arbeitstag ist und,
der.
Weil du viel auf veranstaltungen machst oder warum.
Du bist ja auch ich arbeite im bereich der it-sicherheit das ist jetzt auch gerade nicht der bereich der budgets kriegt ne wenn jetzt bei unternehmen die.
Einnahmen oder bei ihm vielen bereichen jetzt die einnahmen wegbrechen dann werden natürlich solche,
solche sämtliche projekte die nicht absolut essentiell sind.
Oder als solche angesehen werden ja.
Ja die werden halt sofort eingefroren ist ja also wird das das ding ist ja das katze kannst ja verstehen dass das jetzt.
In vorbereitung auf ungewisse wirtschaftliche zeiten jetzt runtergefahren wird sämtliche ausgaben werden runtergefahren werden,
und das ist natürlich blöd ich gehöre aber glaube ich nicht zu denen die das jetzt die,
unmittelbar in eine absolute krise landen,
aber trotzdem freue ich mich ja wenn ihr jetzt alle mehr zeit zum podcast hören habt,
und vor allem euch vergewissert habt ob das in eurem freundeskreis im bekanntenkreis werden sicherlich fälle sein wo jetzt leute sich sehr gut bedient sind wenn sie mal ein fuffi zugesteckt bekommen oder auch mal mehr,
dann könnt ihr euch um die kümmern wenn dann ganz am ende noch was über ist man könnte auch an eure podcaster denken die hier unter lebensgefahr.
Hallo.
Ja du ich das ist gefährlich.
Bin heute fahrrad durch berlin gefahren um hier wenn ich pech habe infiziert hier in alten mann.
Nee nee.
Hallo.
Ja
Ja vielleicht mache ich einen youtube-kanal jetzt wenn wenn ich so viel zeit habe mal gucken ich hab da noch einen.
Gleich auf insta.
Ein ein projekt läuft noch und das es geht es geht noch ich kriege ich werd mich schon melden wenn es hart auf hart kommt.
Schick deinen feed raus und soweit ist der linus vorher der geht voll ab ja.
Also an der stelle auch noch mal danke für die vielen kleinst spenden die über daueraufträge etcetera kommt das,
genau das was so eine situation nochmal doppelt so viel wert ist weil es einfach,
die planbarkeit erhält etcetera man kann halt einfach das weiter tun was man gerne macht nämlich hier senden senden.
Senden.
Mit ordentlichen headsets.
Ich sag dir das team das da.
Ich habe dich du wenn du noch eins brauchst ich kann ja auch noch eins mitgeben.
Du kannst dir nicht vorstellen in so einem.
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen wenn sich da irgendjemand vorstellen kann ich kann mir das vorstellen.
Du kannst dir nicht vorstellen wie viele stunden ich irgendwelchen.
Doch ich kann mir das vorstellen weil ich kenne du weißt doch wie es ist.
Mikrofon ist bescheid und dann ich habe gerade ach weißt du gar nicht leise nein warst du nicht hast du nicht.
Hörer zur seite auf twitter hatte auch irgendwie immer noch dass das dass das telefon conference bingo geschickt das träumchen.
Ja oder wenn ihr da irgendwelche acht personen an einem tisch um um so eine spinne stehen und da reinrufen weißt du und der raum hat eine akustik wie die kloschüssel und dann wundern sie sich.
Wenn ihr wenn ich sage dass wenn das geklärt ist ne dann ist die remote-arbeit ihr werdet nicht mehr zurück zur arbeit wollen aber okay wir wollen wahrscheinlich nicht so fangen wir mit der sendung an.
Ja es gibt ja auch noch andere bedrohungen in der aktuellen situation fake news werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich auch wieder eine ganze menge einsammeln,
sind ja schon eine ganze menge spinner wieder unterwegs verschwörungstheorien machen natürlich auch vor solchen gerade vor solchen situationen nicht halt es hält sich glaube ich gerade noch so ein bisschen in grenzen aber das wird sicherlich nicht mehr lange dauern und es wird irgendwie total überschwappen.
Ich bin gespannt wenn der donald trump erstmal infiziert ist was sie dann in die welt setzen.
Das war oder wie hölle bolsonaro war's.
Italiener oder.
Der brasilianer ist egal.
Haben die demokraten eine eigene krankheit erfunden um.
Also das ist das ist das finde ich dann doch schon ganz angenehm dass donald trump nicht in deutschland regiert keine keine tests.
Das ist hardcore also u s a a ich gehe davon aus dass das dass das große schlachtfeld werden wird weil so also unvorbereitet da kann man ja gar nicht sein.
Und das könnte noch richtig übel werden und dann wird's wirklich lustig mit der weltwirtschaft.
Da haben sie es dann wirklich geschafft durch missmanagement ihrer vormachtstellung sich ihrer vormachtstellung komplett zu entledigen.
Ja aber wir wollen ja nicht so wir wollen ja nicht so wild spekulieren deswegen hoffen wir einfach.
Ja die hoffnung stirbt.
Wir haben feedback gehabt.
Genau gleich mal vorlesen,
moin linus moin tim erstmal vielen dank für eure regelmäßigen sendung ich verfolge sie seit einiger zeit und finde es super auch ohne eigenen technischen hintergrund so nach und nach mehr von der technischen welt um uns zu verstehen super wir diese wichtigen themen immer wieder diskutiert,
ich hatte diese woche das vergnügen den regierungsentwurf für das gesetz gegen hasskriminalität durchzulesen denen das bmw auf seiner webseite veröffentlicht hat und den ihr hier also,
letzte sendung besprochen habt,
ausführlich besprochen habe die grundsätzliche kritik bleibt weiterhin in vielen punkten angebracht insbesondere bezüglich der unmöglichkeit beziehungsweise sinnlosigkeit der passwort herausgabe.
Bezieht sich auf das,
die verschärfung aber jetzt noch gar nicht so gesagt und die pläne hier passwörter zu verlangen aber hier vielleicht eine gute nachricht ganz so schlimm wie ihr es dargestellt habt ist es dann doch nicht.
Kann man wieder übertrieben erstens ein bisschen zu weit gehen eure behauptung,
anbieter sozialer netzwerke würden jetzt dazu verpflichtet selbst strafbare inhalte aufzuspüren die neue netzdg vorgesehene meldepflichten paragraph drei entwurf,
sieht lediglich vor dass die anbieter solche inhalte an das bka melden die ihn selbst in einer beschwerde in der regel von nutzerinnen gemeldet worden sind,
und diese gelöscht oder gesperrt haben.
Diese löschspray pflicht auf beschwerde besteht schon im derzeitigen netzdg diese beschwerden sind zwar keine anzeigen im strafrechtlichen sinn aber zumindest bedarf es eines impulse eines nutzers um das verfahren in gang zu setzen.
Dazu müssen inhalte nur gemeldet werden wenn anhaltspunkte für bestimmte straftatbestände bestehen,
wobei hier natürlich die kritik völlig berechtigt ist dass private quasi als vorgeschaltete instanz über die strafbarkeit solcher inhalte entscheiden müssen und im zweifel eher zu viel löschen sperren oder melden werden,
die meldung enthält auch noch nicht alle bestandsdaten sondern nur den strafrechtlich relevanten inhalt adresse und portner,
das war punkt eins punkt zwei,
alle weiteren bestandskunden nutzungsarten sollen nur auf verlangen der zuständigen behörde im einzelfall,
herauszugeben sein diese hürde ist nicht besonders hoch aber immerhin bleibt zu hoffen dass die datenbank aufgrund mangelnder personaler,
pazifik täten bei den zuständigen behörden nicht ganz so groß wird wie man befürchten könnte punkt drei.
Für die herausgabe von passwörtern und anderen zugang zu konnten gewähren den daten wurde indem nun verabschiedeten regierungsentwurf immerhin die anordnung durch ein gericht zur voraussetzung gemacht,
so dass hier die gleichen maßstäbe gelten wie bei der online-durchsuchung hier hat die regierung im vergleich zum referentenentwurf vom dezember immerhin nachgebessert.
Die punkte zwei und drei sollen zudem nicht im netz der je sondern im telemediengesetz verankert werden und gelten danach nicht nur für soziale netzwerke sondern für
alle sogenannten telemediendiensten worunter nach gesetzesbegründung jedenfalls alle internetseiten von unternehmen fallen also auch banken etcetera.
Das war von ican das glaube ich nicht am anfang gesagt.
Habe ich nicht gesagt richtig danke vielen dank für die ausführliche darstellung.
Vielen dank sehr solche kommentare bitte mehr davon.
Was wir nicht so viel reden.
Müssen wir also in dem fall tim nein wirklich super ich kann auch dazu nur sagen gerade dieses thema habe ich,
da bin ich ja auch hier zum glück das freut mich dann ehrlich gesagt auch das thema habe ich nicht besonders gut vorbereitet und nicht besonders gut behandelt,
und dann bin ich echt auch ganz froh darüber dass dann da eine korrektur dann auch stattfindet ja wenn da ein,
fehler oder ein falscher eindruck vermittelt wurde und dann bin ich sehr froh wenn das in dieser form stattfindet,
freut mich freut mich sehr und ist auch also aus aus verschiedenen gründen schön weil man weil ich daran merke okay hier leute auch wirklich zu und auch menschen die ja weiter ihren.
Die sich auch wirklich für das thema interessieren wir haben.
Bereit sind auch gesetzestext aber genau durch.
Ja genau wir müssen also darum geht's irgendwie ein bisschen hier das interesse für diese themen aufrecht zu erhalten und ja also wirklich vielen vielen dank für den kommentar und freue mich immer wenn so etwas stattfindet.
So wenn ich das richtig sehe bezieht sich auch der nächste kommentar auf diesem bereich linus sagte.
Schon wieder ich mag jetzt reicht's aber auch immer werde ich hier angemacht.
Klar sollte man so viel redest kommentar ist übrigens von speziales experte das heißt das ist jetzt natürlich von besonderer,
minus sagte bestandsdaten auskunft geht es nicht ohne richter vorbehalt,
das ist falsch es gibt nicht nur kein richter vorbehalt das ist zum teil so automatisiert das noch nicht mal die abgefragte anbieter davon mitbekommen siehe,
artikel auf netzpolitik punkt org und dort gibt es dazu weitere informationen.
Er ist artikel von andre meister bestandsdaten auskunft zwanzigachtzehn behörden haben alle zwei sekunden abgefragt wem eine telefonnummer gehört dann geht's also in dem fall jetzt nur um telefonnummern internet eben nicht aber ja offenbar.
Geht das dann doch sehr viel schneller und einfacher ich muss hier nur kurz anmerken dass ich.
Telefonnummer interessieren mich nicht ganz so viel ich habe nicht ich habe den eindruck dass es bei hier steht's auch zur adressen
seit zweitausenddreizehn umfasst die bestandsdaten auskunft neben telefonnummern auch internetdaten vip adressen e-mail-postfächer damit erfahren behörden wem eine adresse zugewiesen ist oder welcher adresse eine zielperson nutzt ebenfalls ohne rechtausschuss ja ganz klar stets da,
über diese abfragen gibt es leider keine statistiken weil die behörden nicht bei der bundesnetzagentur anfragen sondern direkt bei den peace,
interessant ich habe immer noch den eindruck dass das häufig nicht schnell genug funktioniert aber ich freue mich auch hier,
korrigiert worden zu sein.
Drittes und letztes feedback ist von sven und bezieht sich auf etwas worüber wir schon gesprochen haben nämlich die verkäufe,
ich denke dass eine sache die ihr vielleicht vergesst wegen der hamster käufe ist was passiert falls ihr krank werdet dann wollt ihr ja verhindern dass ihr andere leute ansteckt vor allem leute die anders als ihr vielleicht älter sind oder aus anderen gründen mehr grund haben den,
virus zu fürchten.
Dazu zwei sachen ja,
ihr wollt keine anderen leute anstecken deswegen ist social distance nicht eine sache von euch selber schützen wenn wenn ihr korona haben wollt ist mir recht,
aber da ihr diese krankheit dann mit dieser krankheit andere menschen ansteckt müsst ihr das eben alleine zu hause haben.
Und es ist richtig wer krank ist geht bitte nicht mehr einkaufen aber dann bringt euch jemand anderes etwas,
dann ruft ihr irgendjemand an dann kauft jemand anderes für euch ein so das wird insofern glaube ich nicht gerade die leute die gerade mit,
hundertachtundzwanzig rollen arsch papier im kombi nach hause fahren ja dass die wenn du die frage sein ja ich wollte nur kein anstecken ne also ganz ehrlich ich glaube die haben da andere motive am am am abwirken insofern,
ja dann kaufen andere für euch ein und ich glaube ich habe auch relativ viel hoffnung,
wenn das virus ja tatsächlich wie christian trosten vermutet dann doch irgendwie um die sechzig prozent dieser gesellschaft erreichen wird dann,
haben wir relativ schnell auch relativ viele leute die wahrscheinlich immun sind und die können dann auch in die pflege gehen müssen sie vielleicht.
Oder im supermarkt.
Supermarkt pflege und so weiter wir haben eine gute nachricht tippen wer hätte gedacht in einer solchen sendung ja wo es gar keine guten nachrichten gibt,
haben wir aber eine die gute nachricht beginnt mit einer schlechten nachricht.
Aux
Und zwar hat chelsea manning einen suizidversuch unternommen in dieser woche,
wurde dann auch in ein krankenhaus eingeliefert aber die gute nachricht ist.
Ihre beugehaft wurde beendet sie hat.
Und jetzt wird's natürlich ok wenn man diese beiden nachrichten so dann denkt man jetzt eier klar die hat oder könnte jetzt der eindruck entstehen dass das wegen des suizidversuchs so wäre das nicht der fall,
sie hat ihre beugehaft wurde beendet weil der richter entschieden hat in dem verfahren gegen assange sei gar keine aussage mannings erforderlich,
ja es ist gut dass ihm das jetzt eingefallen ist.
Am bundesbesitz gericht für virginia wir hatten in der einer der vorherigen sendung ja darüber gesprochen das und warum das wahrscheinlich in virginia ist und hat eben die sofortige freilassung angeordnet allerdings,
war das ja das war ja sowieso sehr strange sie hatte beugehaft und,
eine beuge strafe finanzielle strafe von täglich fünfhundert dollar für die ersten dreißig tage,
und danach eintausend us dollar pro tag.
Und das hat sich jetzt inzwischen auf grob eine viertel millionen us-dollar summiert.
Dazu würde ich sagen das ist ein betrag der relativ einfach zu.
Der sollte daran sollte es jetzt nicht scheitern.
Wird es auch nicht denn es steht bei zwohundertsiebenundzwanzigtausend dollar die bereits zusammengekommen sind mit einem ziel von dreihundertsechsundfünfzigtausend.
Genau alles klar das heißt diese kohle ist jetzt relativ zügig zusammen und das wäre auch wirklich ein hässlicher fleck,
wenn das jetzt nichts sehr zügig zusammen wäre halte das mal im auge wer weiß wann wir veröffentlichen vielleicht ist es dann auch schon geschehen ich weiß nicht wie das bei mir ist vielleicht gibt's da auch noch ein stretch call nämlich,
ich glaube sie wird ich weiß nicht genau wie ihre lage ist was ihre wohnung angeht und ja.
Wäre das da muss man jetzt halt mal ein bisschen geld hin kippen und dann haben wir diesen mist auch wirklich hinter uns wird sicherlich glaube ich das jetzt,
nicht morgen wieder einsatzbereit sein wenn sie gerade ein suizid,
versuch unternommen hat und solange in haft war insofern denke ich da ein bisschen mehr zu spenden wird nicht so schädlich sein wird es sicherlich sinnvoll einsetzen.
Ja also wenn wir schon relativ sicher dass wenn ich das veröffentliche das ist dann schon durch ist es zahl steigt hier gerade vor meinen augen an,
ja das ist doch schön zu hören die frage ist wie dauerhaft ist das ganze.
Ja also ich vermute ja ehrlich gesagt also dieser.
Diese meldung ja dass deine aussage ist nicht nötig oder nicht mehr nötig da versucht da fragt man sich natürlich auch was das laufende verfahren gegen assange angeht was sie sich denn da so überlegt haben ne,
weil also wenn sie sagen das ist jetzt nicht mehr nötig dass du da was du sagst dann hat vielleicht irgendjemand gesagt naja okay wir haben genug zusammen,
oder vielleicht hat jemand gesagt ist vielleicht besser wenn sie nichts sagt.
Wir bleiben aber bei assange denn auch das müssen wir jetzt quasi nachreichen als meldung und ich habe.
Ich habe da ja schon so ein komisches gefühl bei gehabt als wir über die einlassungen von nils melzer gesprochen haben,
weil er ja das polizeiliche verfahren.
In schweden gegen den assange ausführlich gerückt hat und wir haben das ja hier auch sehr ausführlich wiedergegeben und ich bin einfach mal im prinzip davon ausgegangen.
Dass der eventuell mit den frauen vielleicht schon ein bisschen gesprochen haben wird bevor er eine solche äußerung öffentlich tätigt und es kam aber auch.
Zumindest in diesem interview lass es sich nicht so als hätte er mit den betroffenen frauen gesprochen ich habe das einfach nur im prinzip angenommen.
Und habe ja auch nochmal gesagt so ich mein ganz ehrlich das was da passiert ist so dass entscheidet ja wohl die betroffene person,
und oder welche welches verhalten ihrer widerfahren ist und welches nicht und nun ist es so dass die einen der beiden frauen die zweitausendzehn da zu den,
betroffenen gehörte,
die sich von die von assange bedrängt wurde sie hat jetzt gesagt ich zitiere jetzt mal kurz die lisa ist einfach aus dem spiegel ab ich habe ja ich habe das cookie problem in den griff bekommen,
also auf auf meinem hauptgericht aber irgendwo die mobilen geräten nach wie vor nicht noch nie habe sie sich so sehr missbrauch gefühlt wie durch ihn schreibt.
Die schwedin in einem das je dass sie an mails das büro geschickt hat und dass der spiegel einsehen konnte melzer,
hatte von manipulation durch die schwedischen ermittler gesprochen und die erfindung,
einer vergewaltigungs- erzählung behauptet so jetzt sagt sie schreibt damit schiebt er die schuld den opfern zu eine klassische patriarchalische technik,
die bedingungen dafür zu definieren wie ein echtes echtes vergewaltigungsopfer sich zu verhalten habe,
erhält sie hält dem juristen vor sie persönlich zu verleumdet und teilweise die unwahrheit über die ermittlungen verbreitet zu haben etwa über die bereitschaft assange zu den vorfällen auszusteigen,
zu sagen die ist halt völlig inakzeptabel schockierend und ein grund seine tätigkeit bei der uno zu beenden.
Die haben auch vorher gemailt und er hat in dem kontext sowohl den satz gesagt sinngemäß ich vermute dass in einer schwedisch gemeldet haben mein verständnis der sachlage ist vielleicht noch unvollständig.
Aber und er hat auch deutlich gemacht in anschreiben an die regierung dass er sich mit bezug auf die ereignisse in schweden kein urteil über die schuld oder unschuld von assange anmaßt wohl aber.
Die anschuldigung aufrecht erhält dass die aussagen der beiden.
Der beiden opfer dass sie absichtlich verzehrt,
verbreitet weitergeführt und instrumentalisiert wurden ja und das ist natürlich also da sagt er diese aussage diese anschuldigungen gegen die gegen die schwedischen strafverfolgung hält er aufrecht,
und das ist wäre jetzt auch die entscheidende jetzt sagt aber die schwedin ich glaube nicht,
dass ihre eigenen angaben durch die polizei fingiert worden sind also.
Das sagt auch er er sagt das ja ja also schränkt das ein schränkt diese aussage dass da verzerrt verbreitet instrumentalisiert wurde generell.
Aber nicht das was sie gesagt haben so das was sie gesagt haben haben sie gesagt aber da.
Das bezieht sich nur auf diese frau.
Und ich glaube dass er meint.
Also so gibt es jetzt der artikel auf dem spiegel das wieder.
Wenn ich also für mich ist er ich habe jetzt tatsächlich ein semantisch des problem klar sei für ihn dass sie zweitausendzehn gemachten aussagen vor allem die des zweiten muss man sich ein opfers,
absichtlich verzehrt verbreitet weitergeführt und instrumentalisiert worden sein um assange zu schaden allerdings schränkte er dies gegenüber anna ein ich glaube nicht dass ihre eigenen angaben durch.
Gegen ihr gegenüber schränkt.
Ja durch die polizei fingiert worden sind also er sagt hätte nicht dass das passiert ist und nicht was du gesagt hast wurde fingiert,
aber es wurde verzehrt weiter verbreitet und ist heute.
Okay also wichtig dass man im deutschunterricht gut aufgepasst hat der satz hat's in sich ja okay.
Okay das ist wichtig.
Also nicht dass ihre eigenen angaben fingiert worden sind aber vielleicht später okay.
So interpretiere ich den satz so.
Gut jetzt also da hat er sich jetzt hat er sich auch von menschenrechtsanwälten und jura professoren irgendwie einen offenen brief von dreihundert leuten direkt eingetreten die im eben.
Seine einlassung in bezug auf sexuelle gewalt als rechtlich abträglich abwegig und schädlich bezeichnen und jetzt ist aber natürlich ein punkt das hat anne rot auch.
Nochmal in einem in einem tweet sehr klar gemacht,
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir es halt hier mit zwei sachen zu tun haben es gibt einmal diese ganzen pressefreiheit themen um wikileaks es gibt da die frage.
Der menschenrechte die eben auch für julian assange gelten egal was er gemacht hat und es gibt dann die frage was mit diesen.
Frauen da passiert ist was ein eigenes strafverfahren ist und dann gibt es immer noch die frage ob dieses strafverfahren korrekt gelaufen ist das also vier.
Fragen genau.
Ich denke man kann sich jetzt hier den schon trotzdem noch sagen so dieses strafverfahren ist nicht den üblichen weg gelaufen.
Diese darstellung von melzer würde ich nach wie vor der würde ich nach wie vor folgen und.
Was die situation angeht die mit diesen beiden frauen passiert sind da haben natürlich nur,
diese beiden frauen zu sagen oder zu klären was da jetzt der fall ist und was nicht,
und das ist natürlich eine das hätte den melzer nicht passieren dürfen dass der so dass er sich so hinstellt und große fresse hat ohne mit denen gesprochen zu haben geht nicht.
Tja.
Also für alle beteiligten.
Ist einfach bleibt einfach ein schwieriger fall so also daran hat sich noch am wenigsten geändert.
Gut dann gibt es wir haben ja gerade schon über die öffentliche zugänglich machbarkeit von bildungsmaterialien ein bisschen gesprochen in zeiten der krise,
trifft die uns aber auch in anderen zeiten ist sie notwendig und da gibt es jetzt eine kleine aber feine petition von der wiki media,
nämlich öffentliches,
geld öffentliches gut ja wir kennen die public money public public code kampagnen wo es darum ging wenn etwas mit öffentlichen geldern bezahlt wird dann sei bitte auch der,
dort entstehende quelle code öffentlich zugänglich eine relativ einfache forderungen und,
so wird jetzt auch gefördert gefordert wir ermöglichen mit unserem rundfunkbeitrag die produktion von bildungsinhalte.
Die sollte doch dann bitte auch der öffentliche rundfunk auch frei,
zur verfügung stellen und da geht es also unter einer freien unter einer freien lizenz zur verfügung stellen es gibt nämlich immer noch dieses problem der dem publikation von inhalten und,
sie argumentieren
das hier geht es ums allgemeinwohl hier geht's um steuer einsparungen hier geht es um eine zusammenarbeit ne lehrerinnen und lehrer haben die chance ihre lernmaterialien untereinander zu teilen gemeinsam weiterzuentwickeln und man kann auch außerhalb des unterrichts,
mit den freien bildungsinhalte ein publikum erreichen gibt nur vorteile und deswegen,
setzt sie wiki media foundation sich hierfür ein halte ich für sinnvoll zeigt sich genau,
in zeiten wie diesen denn bildungsmaterialien irgendwie unter verschluss zu halten es ist halt einfach unsinnig ne ist klar dass man irgendwie eine geordnete prüfe und leer strukturen irgendwie haben will um irgendwie mindestmaß an,
bildung eben auch anzufassen und sicherzustellen was nicht alles ja müssen eigentlich genau reingehen aber die materialien dazu,
sollten natürlich frei zugänglich sein insofern haben wir das natürlich auch unterstützt.
Kein aktuelles thema zu dem ich nicht gerade ein podcast veröffentlicht hätte
die allerneuste ausgabe von forschergeist ist nämlich ein längeres gespräch mit leonardo busch der ja auch.
Im zdf fernsehgarten ist genau und mit dem ich über seinen kern forschungsfeld nämlich die organisationsform gesprochen habe extrem interessantes gespräch
gegen ende geht es dann auch tatsächlich genau auch auf dieses thema wir reden halt auch viel über so
open source organisationsform aber natürlich auch mit den öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunk und so kommen dann auch irgendwann konkret auf dieses thema zu sprechen das war jetzt in keiner form abgesprochen,
ich glaube diese kampagne war da schon in vorbereitung und ist dadurch jetzt wieder getriggert noch offiziell begleitet worden aber auf jeden fall mal wieder eins der ganz seitigen gespräche die ich euch nur
naheliegen kann also auch der rest ist sehr interessant.
Und damit sind wir.
Am ende der sendung.
Ende der sendung angelangt es ist natürlich in zeiten des coronas schwierig eine sendung zu machen indem man das vollständig ignoriert ich hoffe aber ehrlich gesagt hin dass wir das in den nächsten sendungen schaffen.
Was genau zu ignorieren das corona thema.
Ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt also mir hängt.
Das jetzt schon zum hals raus sagst du.
Sagen wir mal ich habe mich damit die letzten tage sehr ausführlich beschäftigt und ich habe da jetzt auch für meine psychische gesundheit negative effekte festgestellt.
Und.
Jetzt schon.
Ja ich bin da sensibel wenn ich den ganzen tag nur vom weltuntergang rede ich muss mir sorgen machen um menschen.
Wo du ja sonst nichts anderes passt.
Wo ich sonst immer nur so schöne themen habe ne.
Ja ach ich muss sagen ich finde das alles sehr interessant und ich habe auch versucht jetzt in meinem kanal da schon mal ein diskussions- kanal zu eröffnen,
der war da war die erste folge auf jeden fall ordentlich umstritten aber ich will das begleiten und,
ich bin jetzt gar nicht so abgeneigt weil ich meine das ist nun mal unsere.
Unsere welt jetzt und es auch unsere realität und all die dinge die wir ja auch sonst besprechen werden sich jetzt auch im kontext dieser zustände weiterentwickeln von daher wenn man gar nicht drum rumkommen.
Also ich find's okay ja kann man besprechen aber man muss dann schon,
also erstens wird es wird den leuten noch schnell genug zum hals raushängen und zweitens hoffe ich würde ich mich da gerne zumindest im logbuch auf unsere kernkompetenzen,
beschränken oder unsere kompetenzen beschränken.
Wie wird das ja immer machen.
Nee aber nein wirklich ich glaube also gerade es ist wichtig dass die zeit die jetzt vor uns liegt,
dass da die leute zum sprechen kommen und auch gehört werden die davon wirklich ahnung haben und die jetzt wichtige empfehlungen anweisungen für diese gesellschaft treffen um die hier durch diese,
durch dieses risiko zu manövrieren und zweitens glaube ich dass es da kann ich als psychologe nur,
eine relativ offensichtliche wahrheit aussprechen das ist auch notwendig ist dass die menschen.
Irgendwo ein ein geregelten alltag haben und dann am wenigstens eine eine eine schöne netzpolitische depression pflegen.
Und mal schauen wie es weitergeht aber ich.
Gehört auch zum zum geregelten alltag gehört einfach auch ein paar andere schlechte nachrichten als corona und ja.
Was willst du jetzt noch zu sagen.
Gar nichts ich glaube ich würde jetzt eigentlich nur noch danke sagen und zwar gilt mein dank teresa mario und jan in dieser woche.
Mein dank gilt allen anderen und wir hören uns dann hoffentlich nächste woche wieder.
Wir hören uns nächste woche wieder mal gucken ob remote oder an ort und stelle.
Genau also tschüss.
Passt auf euch auf tschau tschau.
Aux